pourquoi ce qu'elle s'en prendre à la
presse people donc on s'est posé la
question est avec nous nous a rejoint un
journaliste brillant du figaro c'est ça
du tout bien petit et figaro c'est tout
c'est le point pas mal aussi
non plus le point c'est bien ça arrivait
au point et accès et oui ça nous arrange
de sacs de sable
oui voilà son chic mathieu alterman du
point est avec nous alors notamment
effectivement on connaîtrait pas vous
connaissent très bien vous avez beaucoup
travaillé sur mylène farmer sur mylène
farmer oui non plus cette personne
isolée en fait il ya une bosse au
parking j'ai passé cinq semaines farmer
mais disons que je suis journaliste mais
avant j'ai été dix ans producteur de
disques dont dans la maison disait mais
c'est ça la force pâte à bosser un peu
c'est ça alors voilà donc pourquoi ce
qu'elle a créé cette chanson sur
n'apprécie pas les contre la presse
people mais sert que mylène farmer est
né en se construisant contre serre
qu'elle n'apparaissait nulle part parce
que tout bêtement elle était pas bonne
en interview en direct et s'est rendu
compte que ça très très vite
donc l arrêter les interviews en direct
donc on a dit elle se fait rare
c'est un produit de luxe est cool mais
elle a choisi de perfectionner
finalement son image de cette manière
donc aujourd'hui elle est ratée j2 comme
au départ donc c'est une pure stratégie
comme mylène farmer n'est pas une
chanteuse au départ mais l'actrice a
tourné plein de publicité mal et viser
80 pour des ciseaux pour le nom tôt pour
plein de choses
elle est devenue chanteuse parce qu'elle
est allée un casting d'un ami elle a été
casté laurent vidal et actuellement elle
ferma mentor c'est un accord hasard en
fait et est-ce qu'en faisant ça
sébastien s comme dans sa l'appartement
se mettre la presse people à dos quand
on les insulte qu'on les cherche un peu
là les insultes d'un pub dans cette
chanson est ce que du coup ça va pas
vous réveiller pour aller vous venger un
petit peu non ça va pas nous réveiller
en plein sahel elle a une vie qui est
qui nous intéresse pas vraiment les
benjamins après mais à l'opposé de son
personnage donc je pense que c'est pour
ça que les magazines people demande pas
spécialement de photos il n'y a rien
d'intéressant à faire en photo il avait
des amis de nofrag et vous l'avez déjà
paradis voilà enfin si c'est pour avoir
des photos d'elle qui prennent sens chez
en bois de bouleau
voilà où des choses dans le genre c'est
vrai que je comprends que la presse
people soit pas intéressé et je
comprends pourquoi il s'attaqua à la
presse people qui est jamais venu la
chercher si elle arrive à dacca la
presse people je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que malheureusement sur cet album
qui vient de sortir
y'a rien n'y a pas de fond du tout il
faut bien qu'il ya une chanson avec un
petit fond un truc
le restic amis très riches en maths
assumant 30 bc le dernier album c'est
quand même très très léger mais pour toi
pour toi pourquoi l'album et la donne
n'a donc nuls selon vous il a été disque
d'or
l'épargnant album de mylène farmer
cartonne toujours des parce que les fans
la chaîne pendant les quinze premiers
jours et la troisième semaine je parle
depuis 15 ans tout cas du dernier dîner
se vendent moins que cela vous fait
passer c'est plutôt bien écrit c'est
quelqu'un qui sait tous les recherches
qui gardait quand même à voilà voilà
c'est la chanteuse française qui vend le
maison ils ont sorti un ski très s'il
est vrai c'est que sa belle un peu moins
8 à 3 ça reste toujours la chanteuse
numérique est dans le ps d'albums et
vous avez l'industrie du disque est en
mauvaise farce et tous les artistes
vention d'albums et cette séparation
mais en s'en prenant à la presse people
elle crée une belle polémique il faut
aussi parler d'elle donc savez c'est un
petit peu et vous qu'en pensent les fans
qui s'intéressent à son album via clé
donc pour vous catherine elle veut créer
un buzz parce que c'est le seul autour
d'eux et je reçois un monsieur qui dit
comme elle va moins d'albums
celui ci peut être un peu moins bouge
pas compétente pour le juger
créer un buzz comme ça qu'ils aient
repris l'air on en parle la presse
people à présent parler on se demande ce
qui se passe est compris mais rien à
faire je t'embrouille assez ridicule
pour le coup j'adore sébastien mais un
magazine que je connais très bien fait
une coupe en février sur cette cette
artiste et sa super bien cartonné les
gens l'adorent il y avait quoi cette
histoire c'était quoi l'histoire on la
voyait avec avec l'homme de sa vie
derrière ni rien il dit lui c'est que en
gros bas à l'apa damman n'est pas le
colis qu'elle banal mais il n'ya une
nouvelle stratégie de communication il
faut le dire mylène farmer a résisté
pendant trente ans chez universal maison
disque historique et là la changer de
maison disent donc il ya une nouvelle
équipe donc on a envie de créer quelque
chose des mêmes règles
tous les jours justement jean laville
que les joeuurs et malin vous montrez
vous pourrez commenter après un extrait
du jt parce qu'on parle stratégie de
communication pour moi là vraiment on
est au top de la stratégie les silences
la manière et répondent les cheveux
comme ça je pense que tout est travaillé
ou alors j'y comprends rien hein c'est
pas de la 3d on regarde mes lire à brest
à te dérange pas la regarder comme ça
n'est pas comme ça est un des grands
admirateurs de la star alors sage est
tombé 50
ça a été mon premier 45 tours alors
mylène farmer il ya eu des rumeurs ces
derniers jours est-ce que vous pouvez
nous confirmer que vous allez
effectivement remonter sur scène
le dépasser une émotion parce que ça
crée une émotion tout ça d'abord bonjour
luc puisqu'il fait tout il a toute cette
collection et ça me touche énormément
on sait que vous faites de ses concerts
des spectacles à part entière est ce que
vous avez déjà réfléchi à ce que vous
vouliez faire
nous sommes en train d'élaborer le
spectacle et je vais demander humblement
au public de venir à moi paris parce que
je vais rester à paris j'avais beaucoup
de retours et de l'intérêt de retour sur
une salle une scène que j'avais fait à
bercy où on ne voyait j'ai pas en rester
sur place
pardonnez moi c'est l'émission est là
encore très très belle que ça est-ce que
ça se passait toujours dans des bus mis
les années des clés absolument se
construire un personnage un peu ridicule
maintenant mais qui vit dans son donjon
lac est un petit peu seul qui est un
petit peu tri c'est un peu le cas
orelsan et c'est vrai que quand elle se
promène dans la rue élections son mec
est là depuis 15 ans le même qu'elle se
promène les quelques photos qu'on reçoit
déjà chaque fois c'est vrai que c'est un
peu en décalage avec cette espèce de 2,2
d'image un peu de ds laquelle veut
garder depuis 30 ans moi je trouve ça
vraiment rythmé la raison celle raison à
la janis exactement la série janicot
mais les verts n'ont rien à voir dans la
vie privée et à la pesée moi c'est ton
émission c4
les autres finir catherine tu ne l'ès
pas au sénat alors bâti catherine on
écoute catherine s'il vous plaît j'aime
m'a dérangé c'est intéressant mais quand
vous êtes les interviews ya rien de
moins intéressant qu'une interview de
meilleure facture
je ne dis jamais grand chose qui est
très langue de bois qui voit son message
and is elle devient aussi ridicule elle
qu'à son âge et en crawl cash on connaît
là sa demande de l'urssaf
[Rires]
je présenterai trajet elle habitait une
question j'ai une question à vous poser
est donc elle va faire dix ans date
implementation de venir à paris
alors il certains me disent ça s'emballe
c'est un gros show ça coûte cher on peut
pas leur faire en province par dont
céline dion elton john ya plein plein de
noms comme savons céline dion font pas
son champ à clermont ferrand non à ces
ratios d'accord ou n'importe quoi comme
d'habitude assez dit souvent surréaliste
qu'elle fait c'est digne de ddd des plus
des mastodontes américains
donc oui en effet c'est elle on fait
très peu
c'est extrêmement cher d'accord
maintenant pour revenir à ce que vous
dites là les quatre matches de coupe et
kylie minogue a pas de bêtises si on me
le dit hein kylie minogue elle a fait
une tournée où il y avait une piscine
elle est dans toutes les villes dans le
monde entier et en faisait la piscine à
chaque fois venez de l'autre on veut et
ça avait l'air les gens me disent aider
tout ce qu'il faut dans ce cas là ça a
tout ce qu'il faut dans ces cas là c'est
augmenter un petit peu aussi le prix des
cynismes qui veulent y aller peuvent
galère tu vas coûtera toujours moins
cher on perd ça coûtera toujours moins
cher aux fans de plus de payer un billet
plus cher que de faire l'aller-retour
est payante mais mais mais mais mais
vous pouvez applaudir sur le programme
c'est un petit peu de démagogie avec la
france sa mère qui ne la veux dire très
dommage qu'elle puisse pas les en
province en effet c'est très dommage en
revanche vous l'avez dit vous venez de
le dire
ce sont des tournées mondiales que vous
amortissez là il ya treize dates sur
treize dates vous imaginez bien que
shell est assez cérébrale est assez l
etat c comment dire
j'aime
alors je compte le petit benoît le
paraissent en noix qui veut dire dire un
mot et qui reconnaît non mais tout est
question de parler tout est question de
zetman farmer d'ailleurs même avec le
choix de la salle paris défense nanterre
à la choisit cette salle là c'est bien
spécifique parce qu'elle doit être
absolument dans le noir quand elle
arrive c'est pour ça qu'elle joue pas au
stade deux fois parce que c'est la plus
grande d'europe tout simplement
passionnant d'essayer mais je reprenne
en jeu reprend finalement ce qu'elle a
dit dans la presse en fait donc plus
grande des stades de france le plus
grand choix
non non ouvertes on peut pas rentrer
dans dans la lumière en fait l'accolade
de secondes quand on détruit gloriette
moi c'est pas mieux connaître le monde
entier devant le monde entier
voilà alors est au même stade de france
oui magali moi je trouve qu'elle arrive
plutôt en fin de carrière plutôt qu'en
début de carrière et ce titre là non
mais attendez en vue vous écris ces
titres là je pense qu'aujourd'hui elle
fait un peu le bilan est elle dit un peu
merde à la presse people et grâce à ce
titre elle peut vous dire le fc chaumont
déchéance alors lesquels ça n'a qu'à
d'autres causes vous et à la plage on
lui a rien fait mais aujourd'hui ça va
être un non mais c'est peut-être
allez-vous rabelais baisse qui ne peut
pas ne pas baisser alors justement les
amis de trois secondes l'aller - les
bears les paroles et paroles je maudis
les opportunistes c'est vous à grands
coups de triche ça c'est vous dire que
fit ratiches je maudis les riches chiche
les pastilles en plus comme des pâtes au
sel et pato c'est bon sens comprend pas
les journaux n'est pas passé les photos
qu'on fait bitches et commença matin
ml nous dire vous venez nous dire à
trois secondes sébastien pardon mais ça
n'intéresse personne sa vie n'est pas un
ténor mais larry machin il ne passe pas
les photos donc qu'on fait par exemple
quand tu as l'air en jogging avec son
bob dans le baseball senior care oued
qui trancherait avec son image là
d'accord et donc ces gens qui à eux de
ne pas les passer je veux dire que pas
ma coquille j'en connais moins de
lumière d'espérance et une seule dame
normal nous entend pas la bible le star
system comme toutes les normes et c'est
donc là non mais sont un moment donné
[Rires]
ils ont protégé une chanson sur un thème
qui lui met alors tout à l'heure dans le
sujet que sur la radio elle dit je ne
nie pas la patrie la presse people je ne
sais pas ce cadre d'un oui alors c'est
que c'est pas bien mais à la choqué par
la presse qu'une ml peu l'amour
accueillir aussi au sein des clubs
je serai là quand même pas été beaucoup
emmerder avec et alors elle a le droit
les amis sur la tous en même temps
ludivine je vous remercie écoutez mylène
farmer justin dame pour qui j'aurai un
respect mais éternel c'est encore le
même pour toi elle est quand même
détentrice de tous les records depuis
les années 80 il ya personnes en france
qui le fait est là toujours en tout cas
depuis bien des années des années 90 tu
arrêtes cij est faux depuis des années
90 elle cultive le mystère autour d'elle
donc oui elle court comme tout le monde
elle a un chien elles sortent pas
maquillée il n'en demeure pas moins que
son album cartonne
moi je suis pas d'accord avec le fait
qu'on dise quelle fusil la presse people
parce que auquel 10 2 3 trucs mais
c'était un petit coup de buzz qui
recouvrirent son album il ya symbole
nature mais qu'en pense juste à moins de
gens qui pensent que la preuve on sait
pas une part donc on fait pas contre
vous mais ça on dit souvent presse de
caniveau elles disent que tout le monde
pense un puncheur mais c'est pas méchant
ses amis j'étais un petit bois avant qu
on vienne sur la fiche aussi de la
tournée je sais aussi que madame vous
avez une anecdote mais un peu triste non
à propos de m
en fait l'une des vraies que je trouve
assez dur en fait ce qu'ils disent
actuellement parce qu en fait mis un
terme à la vécu la vie c'est pas drôle
elle a vécu un drame
c'est à dire garder l'algérie n'est pas
la passe l'arrière dans les années 80 y
avait un fan en fait chez écrivait
régulièrement à sa maison et d'y être en
main difficile il est arrivé dans 84 85
il est arrivé en fenêtre personne ne lui
répondait à ces lettres et à ses coups
de fil et l'arrivée chez polydor et l'a
tué le standardiste
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
aujourd'hui elle est très secrète elle
est pas le rapport tous à matha et ses
mamelles comprendre que ça va rien dire
dans les années 90 et en quatre ans à
l'époque où juste avant l'arrivée mais
tu sens non vous avez des choses que je
sais faire aussi
c'est cette méchant c'était au sommet de
sa carrière il te tais mais écoutez vous
les a mis là on a un spécialiste alors
lé début de sa quête au sommet de sa
carrière sévère 93-94 polydor était à
l'époque dans le xiiième il n'y avait
pas de garde suite à sa universal
installer un truc et je regarde mais il
n'y a pas eu que vous savez moi j'ai été
pris en otage par un fan de patricia
kaas y avait un flingue
oui parce qu'il voulait rencontrer
patricia kaas oui oui donc bon clair on
n'est plus dans ses pas le flingue qui
m'étonne c'est un fan de patricia corde
[Applaudissements]
et john lennon a été tué par abri sûr et
ronald reagan a subi une tentative
d'attentât par un fan de jodie foster
qui voulait attirer l'attention il ya
quand même des choses de falling bien se
révéler très bons pour y ranger sa les
salariés les bars et les amis des amis
sébastien sur place juste une dernière
chose regarder les affiches ont été
détournés par un bal à part plein
petitjean très drôle notamment sur
internet regarder ça va arriver
voilà voilà voilà
et l'ado troupes à la pause et paraît le
sait bien les beatles et soeurs